the attorney venture example wants
justice for former residents of the
ethnic Germany Colonia Dignidad in Chile
founded by Paul Shaffer in 1961 the
community was based on Nazi and
fundamentalist Christian ideals torture
sexual abuse and even murder were
committed here with impunity for some
for decades Hendel himself was born and
raised here now he's fighting for
compensation for the victims and suing
the Chilean and German governments it's
an ongoing battle
even three temple is heading up to the
former Colonia Dignidad where for 20
years he was subjected to beatings hard
labor and psychological cruelty
it's not a place I like to go back to to
me it's like a workplace I hated by not
to stay more than two or three days at a
time it's hard to be there
it's an emotional strain the road to the
colony is still closed to the public
since 2005 it's been known as the via by
V era or Bavarian village only about 70
colonists as the residents call
themselves remain unwilling to leave the
place where so many were manipulated
beaten and drugged
as hard as it is for him temple has been
coming back to visit for about three
years now he collects evidence
statements and new clients he takes two
of his clients through Paul Shaffers
house the ex leader died in 2010 in the
evenings Schaefer would preach
abstinence and proceeded to molest
underage boys even now few residents are
willing to talk about it
how about Linderman had to overcome deep
feelings of shame Paul Shaffers bedroom
was here behind this door and every
night another boy would have to stay
with him no the memories are not nice I
don't want to say anything more about it
the memories are painful and generally
repressed the residents would rather
look forward than back they've opened
the colony to tourism offering German
folklore and German beer as attractions
it may seem grotesque but they say life
has to go on and after all Schaffer is
dead and buried but Van Fleet temple has
been digging up the past
his father still lives here in a
basement apartment when father and son
talk they steer clear of sensitive
topics oh there you are look what we've
brought you how are you you're spoiling
me we've come armed like all the
colonies children hempel grow up
separated from his parents and siblings
at age 20 he left the colony went back
to school and became an attorney his
33rd birthday was the first he ever
celebrated with his parents we always
had to take photos like these almost
secretly so no one would find out
because it was frowned on for parents
and children to be together at all there
are some photos but it was always a huge
effort to take them making them all the
more precious this photo is worth its
weight in gold to me over a beer then
three temple coffees libros subjects
that people here don't like to talk
about as they're still painful such as
the forced separation of children from
their mothers I was just four and she
wasn't allowed contact with us anymore
she was torn away from us completely
we were totally at Schafer's mercy
totally when he called for us at night
our great father what a scumbag
let the little children come to me
that's God's Word but when I learned how
it was misused what could I do I can't
put it into words I cried my heart out I
had no idea Schaefer was doing things
like that he was always very careful to
make sure the parents found out as
little as possible about what he was
doing that much is clear
VIN fleet handle doesn't confront his
father at least not this time he's never
been able to persuade him to join the
class-action suit you can't speak freely
about the topic you can only touch upon
the subject but you can't bring it all
out into the open because for my parents
that would mean tossing their entire
lives not just their past but their
entire lives in the trash
my father 75 now
temple has been preparing his
class-action suit for three years now
many colony residents see him as a
troublemaker he constantly has to
justify what he's doing we didn't do
that at all we didn't take cameras into
any homes where anyone might feel
hassled not at all I was in a public
space filming but that's all that any
tourists would do I'm allowed to aren't
I calm down then I've got more respect
for people that I'm often given credit
for here yeah okay Thomas goodbye
the director jizz now called me because
we're supposedly harassing people in
their homes which is totally far-fetched
let us bother because I'm here and
they're probably upset that we're
showing the truth from an inside
perspective and they don't want it
presented to the outside world that way
in 2013 half of Lindemann realized he
had to get away from this place now he
lives in southern Chile and has joined
VIN frayed hempen effort the colony
residents see him as a traitor demise
they have young weekly all free most of
us here were sincerely looking for
guidance from the Bible and trying to
dedicate ourselves to God and his
teachings and they say we turned away
from God in his teachings the way we
lived here for 40 years
how about Lindemann is talking about his
past for the first time on camera it's
hard the rule has always been never to
speak in public about the abuse beatings
and torture most of the residents are
old now and they avoid contact with
reporters many younger residents are
more open some have left the colony and
are willing to confront the past but
others have trouble overcoming the years
of brainwashing
you could go door to door and try to
speak to the victims but in the
religious sense they feel like they're
being damned so you can't approach them
you can't get through to the victims
because they see you as a black angel
come to take them to hell that's the
problem
Augusto Pinochet's military dictatorship
used the colony to incarcerate and
torture dissidents Chile and Germany
both long turned a blind eye and have
been slow to accept any responsibility
we actually had a double legal system
enforce the German and the Chilean he
could have provided double legal
protection but both systems failed
now Hempel intends to hold them to
account
he's heading back to Santiago there he
meets with Efrain feather another of
Colonia Dignidad victims he's joining
the suit for compensation from the
Chilean and German states they discussed
the case in fellows office a central
exhibit is a document that made the
underaged Fedders illegal adoption
official my father allegedly signed the
document even though he was already dead
at the time the document says my father
gave me up for adoption but he wasn't
even still living is the adoption
recorded in this official document from
1976 to be exact October the 4th 1976
precisely 12 months after his death the
message is put it makes you feel so
powerless it's really a breach of state
responsibility the damage the state
inflicted on us and so many other
Chileans has to be compensated
is also demanding compensation for
himself and he's not charging to
represent the other victims he's after
something far more valuable justice I
know how hard this battle is going to be
I'm aware of that it's like David
against Goliath but in the original
story David won and I have faith you
clearly saw
Vinh three temple and fim feta are on
their way to see a notary it's an
important step Afghan fella is handles
one hundred and twentieth client in his
class action suit
cameras are strictly limited at a
notary's office the attorney and his
client are nervous but relieved
if remote a few more now if rain has
signed the brief like 119 clients before
him now I can prepare the case over the
coming months and file it a few months
after that the guilty parties will be
held accountable and the many Chilean
and German victims will finally receive
justice they've endured things that
should never have happened and I hope
nobody else in history will ever have to
endure again let's get to work
thanks let's stay strong the suit
against the Chilean state is due to be
filed in November and the one against
Germany next year
burnfree Campbell is determined to see
justice done for the victims of Colonia
Dignidad
you